I have a ton of questions for you um you
have done a ton of things through your
career if hypothetically someone has
seen nothing that you've done out
obviously besides Candy Cane Lane what
is the first thing you'd like them
watching and why that's
tough uh you know uh I listen to my fans
and there's always a house party
Boomerang house party Boomerang right
there's that kind of thing right uh cuz
those really defined my career very
early on but then you know in the latter
half you've got no Marshall no black
Godfather no Sydney you know so the
documentaries in the biop piics there
that's a that's a fan base too so uh I
I'd leave it up to somebody else that's
the Diplomatic answer so something else
is you've produced a lot of award shows
and I am curious what do you think would
surprise people to learn about what it's
really like producing an award show
well it's I you know award shows can be
really fun because first of all you get
to work however briefly with some of
your favorite Stars right because
they're there to present the award and
you're like whoa I'm talking to Morgan
Freeman hey there's Chris Evans over
there oh here's Sissa Stallone oh here's
the rock uh and you know so that's
really fun what's also great about an
award show is that the minute the show
is over you're done with your job you
walk away there's no editing there's no
post- production you get in your car you
go home and there's something really
there's all this work up front and then
boom that's it I had actually thought
about that um jumping into why I get to
talk to you you obviously worked with
Eddie on Boomerang in
9192 uh how long have you guys been
talking about uh doing something else
together you know we run into each other
and we'll you know I'll throw an idea
out he'll throw an idea out you know
we've been trying to find the right
thing and with this one it just was
magical uh I was talking to a studio I I
expressed my love for Christmas movie
but want to find something different
something original and they said well
we've got this script I read it this is
great you you start you think it's one
movie takes a heart left turn to a whole
other movie then third act say big
surprise I said I love this movie and
they're like yeah and Eddie Murphy's
attached I'm like oh we're done let's
start on Monday let's just get to work
right exact exactly um so I really
enjoyed I thought the animation of the
animated characters looked great and I'm
just curious can you talk a little bit
about pulling that off and the look you
were going for with those characters
yeah it was so much fun uh and and the
thing is you go okay I want to see you
know the glass figures like you you know
hang on your tree come to life well no
one's really done that before right so
you know you you turn to the greatest of
special effects house in the world
industrial lightning magic they brought
us Star Wars in Jurassic Park they can
figure this thing out uh and it would
took a while to you know figure out the
look but man they nailed it and I said
look I don't want it to be perfect
animation you know I I'm really inspired
by Rudolph the reo's Reindeer and that
Rank and bass style animation I said I
want Rank and glass H how do we do that
and uh there was a lot of
experimentation with that uh we didn't
do stop motion but I wanted that feeling
uh like uh for the folks who saw the
Doctor Strange movie that Sam Ry did
multivers of madness he you know he's a
big stop motion fan and he did a version
of it but that was really inspirational
to me so I said no it it's going to work
guys let's go for it and we I think they
nailed it so I'm always curious about
the editing process because it's where
it all comes together so how did the
film possibly change in the editing room
in ways you didn't expect after showing
it to people uh well there's always big
shocks I mean first of all we shot a lot
of movie so we knew uh there was going
to be some big deep Cuts uh but don't
always know where they are because
you're having a good time it's all funny
and what I like to do I have little
friends and family screenings like every
other week when I'm still doing my
director's cut I try to put together the
movie really fast it's fast and it's
sloppy but whatever let's just take a
look at it and get some fresh eyeballs
on it so I invited my daughter she's 18
uh normally she just shows up to the
premiere I'm like you're old enough I'm
going to have you go to see a very rough
very not well-made version of the movie
and see what you think and afterward she
goes daddy thanks for inviting me but
I've got a party to go to tonight I go
well I appreciate you give giving a
little bit of your time to Dad she gives
these notes which are brutal you just
need to cut this cut this cut this and
then I think you got a movie uh she
left uh and I said well and they said
what do you think Reggie I said I think
we do everything my daughter said and
they said we agree and when is she going
to run a studio
so that's that you know the truth is
though I I'm friends with a lot of
directors and they say when like
sometimes people show up and they want
to be nice to those events and that's
not the time to be nice those early
screenings you know I tell this is my
Preamble I say this is the time to tell
the truth if I only inv invite you to
the premiere then only say nice
things CU it's too late but now is the
time to kick my butt because I can
actually fix it 100% um before I I know
I'm G to be running out of time with you
soon but I have to ask you so a project
you're attached to is black cotton star
and that is a like it just sounds
awesome like it you know what I mean and
so what can you tell people about it
what's the status of this thing it's an
awesome uh story it's based on a French
graphic novel it's uh set in a black
platoon during World War II but it has
uh uh a a big historical Arc to it and
it's a kick kickass action movie but it
also um is a real big Ideas behind it so
it's kind of you have your cake and
needed too uh it's really coming along
great we've got a a really a heck of a
script uh we're starting to put together
the team uh so I don't know when it's
going to go it's not officially you know
it's just something I'm we're doing
inhouse but boy I'm I'm really thrilled
about it so hopefully I'll we'll get
that going soon yeah uh for it it's it
just sounds very very cool than we feel
the same you know um so um what I like
learning the behind the-scenes like
stories about making a movie so what do
you think might surprise people to learn
about the making of Candy Cane Lane well
you know it was interesting we actually
invented a new piece of technology this
is what I'm talking about this is what I
want to know you know and I really set
out to not do that I said guys I don't
want to be so fancy with our effects
that we have to go around inventing
stuff but we ended up going around
inventing stuff uh and when I say we I
don't mean me I mean uh my amazing
special effects team um cuz I said look
we've got you know real life people and
we've got the figurines which aren't
real there's there's nothing there uh
but I don't want to shoot this in a way
that you film one side then you film the
other side and because of that the
actress can't interact real time improv
you know come up with new jokes I want
to shoot this like I would shoot it if
there were real people there
so they were like huh well we've never
really done that I say well we're going
to do it today so uh we so we had the
actors there they were off camera uh in
a separate set of booths so we could get
their voices cleanly and we set up we
they they built this amazing device
called the Rudolph system right and we
put little lights where the miniature
actors would be and whenever they spoke
a light would light up so that the the
the the real life actress would know
where to look right because it's all
about the eyeline so we invented this
thing and it was a lifesaver and we got
the same kind of we didn't impede the
creative process of the actors uh at the
same time we were were able to get the
the the right looks that we needed when
we cut the movie together yeah can
imagine that that's a huge difference um
I gotta W I got to stop so I'm just
going to say congrats uh I hope it's a
huge hit and I really do hope you're
making this other film next year um I
agree with everything you just said
thank you have a great day thank you so
much